[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
AUDIENCE: Hi,
Professor Townsend.
Can I ask a question
about the income factor
on the Slutsky equation?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I noticed that
in the last lecture slides,
the income factor, you'll note
that it was x multiply data x
over [INAUDIBLE]--
why it is not minus x
modify data x over data y.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: You're
wondering about the sign.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, it is
confusing because the way that
equation is written,
it looks as if we're--
I can't remember.
Which way is it written?
Minus, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, minus x.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Subtracting
the income effect,
but the graph on
the previous slide
says we're adding
the income effect.
If prices go down and income
effectively increases,
then you buy more than you would
if you held income constant.
So the answer to the
puzzle is the demand
curve figures have
reversed the dependent
and the independent variables.
That is to say, we
usually write dy dx,
where y is the
dependent variable,
x is the right-hand side
independent variable,
but the demand curves actually
put price on the y-axis.
So it's the inverse slope,
if that makes sense.
So the slope dy dx, as written
in that Slutsky equation,
is the inverse of the
slope in the diagram.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Yeah, don't worry.
I stumble over that myself.
I was pondering
it, and I actually
asked Michael to look at it.
And I'd forgotten that
strange labeling that we use,
so it is a little bit unusual.
Thank you for
asking the question.
I do always start the class.
So you've got us off slightly
early, but that's fine.
Are there other questions?
The reading list for this
lecture, it's just one starred
reading here, Kreps chapter 7.
So again, a lot but not
all of the material today
is in that text, and it's
starred for a reason.
I think you will
find it to be very
helpful to read through it.
Let's see.
So that's that.
And then the study guide
on what we did last time.
OK, income and
substitution effects--
can someone volunteer
to answer this request
to discuss Engel's law?
Be as clear as possible
about the data used,
and what you would find if
you look at the data properly?
AUDIENCE: Engel's
law is the law it
says that the higher
proportion of your income
is spent on food, right?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: The
higher is your income,
some good expenditure
shares go up,
and some expenditure
shares go down.
So the exact statement of it
was, I guess, in this figure
with the data.
And food is a necessity,
so the consumption actually
goes down or rises less
rapidly than income does.
So thank you.
So that's where it
is in the lecture.
One comment I have, this is
about expenditure shares.
It doesn't say the
quantity of food.
It says 3 times the quantity
of food is going up.
So expenditures for
food are going up.
It could be a normal good.
But it's not going up as fast
as total income is going up.
So last time I drew what I
called an income expansion
path, which traces out
the locus of tangencies
as income rises,
holding prices fixed.
And if they were linear,
then the expenditure shares
are constant.
That is to say, income goes up.
The amount spent on
the first good goes--
the amount spent on the
second good goes up.
Everything is rising
proportionally.
In order to get the
expenditure share
to be not rising
as fast for food,
you have to have
those income expansion
paths be somewhat curved
so that you don't get
a proportional rise in food.
And really, answering
a question that
was asked in class
last time, or at least
what I thought about
afterwards might be helpful.
Another way to say this.
We talked about Giffen goods.
Oh, well, maybe
that's a question.
So someone volunteer to tell
me, what is a Giffen good?
AUDIENCE: It's when the
price and the quantity
demanded move in
the same direction.
So if the price of something
goes up, then you want--
then you buy more of it.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's right.
OK, perfect.
Perfect answer.
So the point is,
the quantity is what
we have in mind when we
talk about Giffen goods,
not price times quantity,
not expenditure shares.
What creates a
Giffen good is a good
which is not normal,
that is to say,
where expenditures are
falling, relatively speaking,
as we increase income.
And the point is there's two
effects of price changes.
Engel's law is about
income changes.
Giffen's paradox is
about a price change.
But the price
change can be broken
into two pieces,
the substitution
effect and the
consequent income effect.
And the substitution effect
does mean that as price goes up,
you would demand less.
But the income effect means
that as price goes up,
you have effectively
less income.
And if it's a
necessity, then you're
going to spend relatively
less on that good.
So that's the-- tends to
make the quantity go down,
so it's about income
effect dominating
the price effect with
implications for quantities.
I hope that's helpful.
Another way to say this is when
we look at income expansion
paths just changing
income, we're not
moving the price around at all.
And we are assuming somehow
you can make comparisons
across to different
income groups,
that they're all
facing the same prices.
It's just that some people have
more income than others, which
is effectively what would
happen for a given individual
if somehow a poor individual
were given more income.
But it's all about moving income
around in the cross-section
or as if, over time
for a given individual,
holding the prices
fixed, whereas the Giffen
good has to do entirely
with just changing prices.
Income changes only as a
consequence of the price
change, and the Giffen
good is about quantity.
So I hope that's helpful.
Can someone do
the last one here?
Compare and contrast the
utility maximization problem
with the expenditure
minimization problem.
Essentially, give a
statement of duality.
What does duality mean?
AUDIENCE: Yep, so
the duality just
means that these two ways of
formulating the consumer's
choice problem are, in
fact, just identical.
Utility maximization
says given a budget,
what's the highest
utility I can achieve?
And expenditure minimization
is given a level of utility
I want to hit, what's
the minimum budget I
need to hit that?
And these two will, they're
basically identical problems
of each other.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Perfect.
That's a perfect answer.
Thank you.
I can't add anything.
OK, so as always,
it's quite apparent
these are review questions that
you should go over after class
and before the next
class to make sure
you're really
following the material
to go with the production
lecture, lecture 4.
To get reoriented,
we have an economy,
which consists of preferences,
endowments, and technology.
Last two lectures, we
focused on preferences.
Oh, I should have also said,
the application at the end
having to do with
borrowing and lending,
in addition to labeling
the goods by the date, date
1 and day 2, it
was quite apparent
that we had also actually
plotted the endowment.
So that was a bit
different than what
we had been doing with good
x and good y, where we just
talked about income.
So in addition to having income
i as exogenous in that diagram,
we had the
endowments, the amount
of money they had in day
1, the amount of money
they had in day 2, and
plotted the endowment
point in the diagram.
Which is actually,
either way is fine.
But we did add more information.
Anyway, you've seen
endowments and preferences.
Today, we're going
to do technology.
In choice of
overproduction plans,
we'll explore some
possible properties
that technology sets can
have, as we did for consumer
preferences, so on.
And then we'll go
to the application,
which is going to be similar
to what we did for households.
We're going to have firms
maximizing profits given
a production possibility set.
And we'll take that
into an application.
And actually, by the
end of this lecture,
we will actually look at
our first entirely specified
economy, Robinson
Crusoe economy,
and begin to talk about
international trade.
So this slide is meant
to portray technology.
It's a picture I took, actually,
in Northern Thailand, where
I was doing my field research.
And if you're really
into economics,
you'll start talking about land,
labor, and capital as inputs
into production.
And here you see all three.
The land is kind of obvious.
He's getting ready to plant.
Labor, this guy,
who's showing off,
by the way, because he's
not using any hands.
He's not grabbing the
handlebars on what you might
think is like a lawnmower.
And then this tiller, which
they call an iron buffalo,
replaced the buffalo that
used to do the plowing,
and it's just this small
horsepower motor driving
the treads on the wheels.
But anyway, that's the capital--
land, labor, and capital.
So a picture is worth 1,000.
Anyway, production,
OK-- so firms
possess production
capabilities, meaning
some commodities are inputs.
Others are outputs.
And the capability is described
by a set of possible values,
which you can
think of as vectors
with inputs and outputs,
or some people say netput.
If we have the number of goods,
including inputs and outputs,
being of dimension
capital K, then a vector
has dimension capital K, and the
set of all feasible production
vectors is called the
production possibility set.
Now, we do have a
convention, namely,
inputs are negative, or
at least not positive,
and outputs or positive,
or at least not negative.
And with a couple of exceptions,
I'm going to continue that.
It is easier to interpret
if we designate the inputs
and talk about labor
and capital and land
as being positive into
a production function
to get rice as the output.
But for reasons of very
succinct accounting,
it's quite useful to have
the inputs as negative
and the outputs as positive.
You'll see more of that powerful
notation a little bit later.
Anyway, so for example, if we
have three commodities, two
of which are inputs,
say, labor and steel,
numbered 1 and 2 in the
vector, and the output
being safety pins,
then, for example,
we have a netput vector of
minus 5, minus 8, and 10.
And the inputs
are each negative,
and the output, the steel
safety pins, is positive.
So not too hard.
More generally, Z could be a
production possibility set.
Sometimes we call
it Y. I apologize.
We used different sources here.
We can write Z from 1
to K as this vector,
where, again, K is the
number of commodities.
And if we wish, we had a firm J,
we could index everything by J
and talk about the production
possibilities set of firm J
and the inputs j1,
j2, through jK.
And then we drop the j
for most of this talk.
Now, this is very similar to
what we did for consumption.
We had x1 through
xL, I think it was.
And then we put an i
for [INAUDIBLE] needed.
So here, we're dropping the j.
Here's a picture of a
production possibility set, Z,
where we have one input
only, and it's negative.
The more negative it is,
the larger the quantity
being utilized is.
And likewise, if you use more
of it, you get more output.
This entire speckled
region is illustrative
of the entire production
possibility set.
You don't have to be
on the boundary, which
is the maximum output you
can get for a given input
in order to be in the set.
That boundary is typically
included in the set,
but so are these
interior points.
So here are possible properties.
And again, just like
for the household,
we didn't insist that every
class of every production
possibility set
contain each of these.
In fact, some of them
contradict each other,
as you'll see in a minute.
So we usually assume
it's not empty.
I mean, why are we writing it
down if there's nothing to do?
Closed means it
contains its boundary.
That's one way to say it.
Another is just that
every limit point in--
every sequence that
consists of points
in the set that converges has a
point that is also in the set.
That's a technical condition.
I'm sure you've noticed I'm
not overdoing the continuity
part and the closure part.
It's a bit more
technical than we need,
and these properties
are pretty intuitive.
No free lunch means that
whenever Z is in the set
and has no negative components,
you can't get any output.
So Z is a vector.
Z can have positive and
negative components.
Here, writing this Z
vector being non-negative
means that no
component in the vector
is negative, which means
they're either 0 or positive.
And if they were, say, all
0, then you have no inputs,
and you can't get any output.
You can't get lunch out of that.
And that's the expression
"no free lunch."
This is used by
cynical economists
to mean something else, which
means if someone offered you
something for free, be
careful because there may be
[INAUDIBLE].
Anyway, I won't
share that too much.
Convexity-- if you have two
elements, Z and Z prime,
in the set, then the
alpha-weighted combination
is also in the set.
We did this with
consumption sets,
so this is not surprising.
Free disposal means
that if you have
a vector Z in the production
set and Z prime is not higher--
say it's less than
or equal to Z--
then that Z prime
is also in the set.
This is called free disposal.
There are two ways
to look at it.
It's kind of the same.
One-- suppose Z prime
had the same amount
of all the negative
inputs, quantities
of all the inputs, which are
negative, but at less output.
So the positive components
are not greater and maybe
extremely less.
Then you're perfectly free to
throw away that extra output
and maintain yourself in the
production possibilities set.
A little less
obvious, if Z prime
were say strictly less than Z
because the input quantities
are actually higher--
and again, the negative
makes it look like it's less.
Higher inputs means a
bigger negative number.
Then that's also in the set.
Why?
Because if you've
got more inputs--
say you're maintaining
the same output.
Well, if the inputs
were at all productive,
you would have had more output.
But you throw away that output.
That's the free disposal again.
And then, finally, you
can always shut down.
Most, I think, production
functions, production sets have
that property,
that 0 is feasible,
which is a bit different
from saying it's empty.
It means 0 is in there, but
other things are usually
typically also in there.
So three other properties--
decreasing returns to scale.
And I'll show you some pictures.
If Z is in there and
alpha is less than 1,
then alpha times Z
is also in there.
So decreasing returns
actually means
you can scale back something
in the production function,
like US Steel blast furnaces.
And somehow they can pare that
down and make a smaller one.
So it may not be true, but
that's what the property is.
Constant returns
means that you can
scale up or down
willy-nilly and still
have the vector alpha Z in
the production set when Z is.
And increasing returns
goes the other way.
If you have Z in the set
and alpha is greater than 1,
then alpha times Z is also
in the production set,
which means, in this
case, to continue
the example of US Steel.
If you still has one
big blast furnace,
they can just as easily
have two or three.
They can run them.
OK, so let me draw
you some pictures.
This is decreasing
returns, which intuitively
comes from the
curvature declining
of the boundary of the
production possibility set.
The property says if
you're given Y in the set
and it's not 0, then
alpha between 0 and 1
times Y is also in the set,
which these things are.
This is increasing
returns, which is,
whoa, getting
steeper and steeper,
and then there's [INAUDIBLE],,
but it's instructive.
So this is the
same alpha Y, yes.
But the property of
increasing returns
says if you have Y, say, here
and alpha is greater than 1,
then alpha lies in the set.
So, actually, the error--
we'll fix this, I guess--
is that the alpha Y should
have been depicted out here
in the production set.
All this area is in
the production set.
And then constant returns is
neither of those extremes.
It's just a linear boundary.
And it says if you pick
anything in the set,
say, here, and then draw
a line, a ray, from the 0
through that picked
point, everything
on that ray towards 0 or out
to infinity is also in the set.
And I guess we should have
put alpha down here instead
of lambda, but it's
kind of obvious.
So constant returns
to scale is going
to have some strong properties,
which we'll come to.
One word about aggregating
up production sets--
so this is one of the
exceptions, where what--
well, this is the
classic picture.
Inputs on the x-axis.
Output on the y-axis.
This would be the
production set.
Here's a point on
the boundary of one
firm's, labeled
number 1 firm here.
Also, the exception is we're
labeling firms 1 and 2.
This is the production
set of another one
that actually uses as an input
the output that this produces.
And I'll come back
to that later.
In this case, the inputs
and outputs are reversed.
And finally, we have
an endowment point.
So we wanted to add
all these things up
and get the aggregate
set of possibilities.
You got to do a lot
of vector algebra.
But essentially, what's
going on here is start at 0.
That's feasible.
It uses less than endowment.
That's fine.
Then find y1 on the first
production set-- y1.
Then add that endowment back in.
Notice this, the
parallel line shift.
And then, so far, we've
been keeping y2 at 0,
but let's move y2 to something
non-trivial production.
That movement here is the
same as this movement here.
So at this point, which is,
of course, the sum of y1, y2,
and z1, is feasible
because it comes
from these three possibilities.
So this larger area out here
is the aggregated or aggregate
production set.
Now let's talk about
the firm's problem.
So we're already getting
into an application now.
There are these prices, p,
which the firm takes as given,
just like the household
took prices as given.
And the firm wants to come up
with a plan, input-output plan,
to maximize its profit.
So this capital pi here is just
a statement of prices time pk
times zk, summing
up over all the k's.
And here, again, it looks
like everything's positive.
What a wonderful world.
But some of these z's are
required to be negative.
And hence, [INAUDIBLE]
times a negative object.
So there's expenses in
here and revenues in here.
And then when we talk about
the firm's problem, which
is FP, for Firm's Problem,
is to maximize the profits
by choosing feasible points
vectors in the production
possibilities set.
So this very cryptic abbreviated
notation, max p of z,
[? proves ?] z and z.
And here's our picture.
So inputs, which are
negative in sign,
outputs, which are positive.
These guys here, these
linear hyperplanes,
represent possible
profit levels.
Call them isoprofit lines.
When we introduced
indifference curves,
I said it might be better to
call them isoutility lines,
and I was anticipating
this slide
and another one that's coming.
So an isoprofit line means
as you, say, use more inputs
but get more output, you have
expenses balancing revenues,
and you stay on this line.
If you go put in lower inputs,
so for the same prices,
you would have higher profits.
The slope of any
isoprofit line is just
price of output divided
by the price of input,
like p2 over p1.
And of course, we're
depicting this tangency
as the maximum profit line.
You could be in the
interior, but then you
would not be maximizing.
So let's call little pi of p
to be the maximized profit, not
just any old profit, which
was capital pi a minute ago.
This is the best choice
of production vector
z in the production
set, given price
is p. p is a parameter here.
This is, quote,
partial equilibrium, so
we index the solution by p.
Of course, we'll do
experiments where we vary p.
There are some profits--
properties of the
profit function,
namely, this profit
function pi is
homogeneous of degree 1
in the price vector p.
Homogeneous of degree 1 means
that if you scale prices
up by some proportion,
like doubling them,
then maximized profit
should also double.
The reason that should
be obvious, at least when
you think about it, if
we're doubling prices,
we're not changing the slope.
So we're not changing
the maximizing choice.
But we have changed the
levels of the prices,
and the levels means even
though the z's aren't moving,
the prices are moving.
If prices have
doubled, then it must
be that profits have doubled
and constant returns to scale.
Homogeneous to
degree one, sorry--
homogeneous to degree 1.
Profit function is continuous.
It's actually true much more
generally than you might think,
but I'm not into emphasizing
continuity too much these days.
Profit function is convex.
That's an np.
So that's an
interesting property.
So let's look at that one.
The profit function is convex.
OK, what do we want to show?
If we have two p's--
two prices p and [INAUDIBLE]
the associated profits, pi of p
and pi of p prime, then we
take the linear combination
of the prices, say, p double
prime, this alpha weighted sum,
the associated profits
should be not greater
than the weighted
sum of the profits.
So I said that in words.
It's probably just a whole lot
easier to do the mechanics.
So we start with two
prices, p and p prime.
We pick an alpha.
We consider p double prime
to be the alpha-weighted sum.
We let z be the solution to
the firm's profit maximization
problem at p double prime.
So in other words, that
special maximized profit pi
of p double prime is just
p double prime times z
because z is the solution.
Now, z, therefore, was feasible.
It was in the production
possibility set.
So even though we
changed the prices,
that z remains feasible,
which means whatever solves
the problem at p, it cannot
deliver a lower number than
this and may deliver
a higher one.
The profit-maximizing
solution at p
might involve a different
z different from z.
And likewise, the
profit-maximizing solution
at p prime can only be
not lower and maybe higher
than p prime
evaluated at this z.
OK, so now we do the math.
We want to show that
pi at p double prime,
which is, by definition,
p double prime at z.
Remember the starting point.
We're starting at
p double prime,
and we're told that
z is the solution.
So this is p double prime z.
But p double prime
written out is just alpha
p, 1 minus alpha p prime--
that was the
definition-- times z.
And now we invoke each of these
two weak inequalities and say,
well, alpha p times z is
alpha pz less than pi of p.
So the inequality is
less than or equal to,
and we get the same
thing for p prime.
Sorry, I think the ratio of my
words to what's on the slide--
I must have talked
for three minutes.
But there's only four
lines here, so I apologize.
Alpha function is convex, maybe
weakly, but it's not concave,
or not strictly concave.
It may be convex
or strictly convex.
OK, so we'll come back
to that momentarily.
Homogeneity-- two
more properties,
and back to convexity.
So if f is a real
valued function,
mapping rn into r
and k is an integer,
we say f is
homogeneous of degree k
if whenever you scale the
arguments of the function up
by--
the arguments of the function
v by alpha, the value
in the domain goes up by--
in the range goes up by
alpha to the power k.
So homogeneous of degree 0
would mean nothing changes.
Homogeneous of
degree 1 we just did
for profits, where
k is equal to 1,
and this is the most
general concept.
Another property of
the profit function--
it's continuously
differentiable.
So I'm going to show
you an expression
with the derivatives.
If you take that function, which
has as a parameter the price
vector p, and differentiate the
maximized profit with respect
to, say, the k-th item, pk,
holding all the prices--
doing it locally around the
maximizing value p star,
then the solution is the input.
You get the input back.
Derivative with respect to
pk, you get the input zk.
A quick, maybe
misleading, intuition
for that is you
write down profits--
p1, z1, p2, z2, et
cetera, et cetera.
Take a derivative at
the maximizing solution
The derivative is
with respective pk.
Where does that show up?
It shows up in the pk,
zk term, so it seems
like this ought to be true.
Actually, what it's
using is the convexity.
So this thing is called
Hotelling's lemma.
Here is the actual
profit function, but now
with all the prices.
It's actually got a star on
everything but the k-th price
here, no star.
But we're going to
evaluate profit at star k.
So we're right here on
this profit function.
This would be the maximized
profit in general,
and also the maximized
profit in particular
when the price of the k-th
input or output is pk.
What is this n?
And this is like a tangency?
It's a straight line.
And what is this straight line?
That's just what I
was saying in words.
That's just the evaluation
of inputs and outputs
at this price vector star,
and it starred everywhere.
OK, so pk doesn't
have a star here.
But because we're plotting
everything is a function of pq,
but there is a particular
pk, namely pk star,
where we can evaluate
that linear function.
Now, the point of
the tangency is
that the curved function,
the profit margin,
and this linear function
have the same slope.
So if we want to know how the
profit function is changing
as we change pk locally,
we can just as easily
show how this straight
line is changing
as we change pk locally because
they have the same slope.
And how is the linear function
changing as we change pk?
Well, it's just
changing linearly.
So that's the
derivative, namely zk.
So that's the proof of this.
So we did actually use the
convexity of the profit
function, and the picture
is strict convexity.
It actually works
more generally,
but it would be a pretty
hard picture to interpret.
Now, this is also illustrative
of something else called
the envelope theorem, and I'll
just show you the definition.
Oh, and remember
the strategy here.
Tools-- so every so often,
we bump into a concept
that generalizes.
In this case, we just went
over some example of something
called the envelope theorem.
So let me give you a statement
of the general theorem.
If fact, [INAUDIBLE]
[? set ?] and let
t be some parameter
of the problem.
We have a function
f mapping elements
in the choice set
in that parameter
into some real valued objective
function, namely like this.
So put max here if
you're more comfortable.
So f is the thing
we want to max.
We want to max it
by choice of x.
But we have a parameter
in the problem called t,
so we denote the solution,
the maximized value of f, at t
to be V of t, the
value function at t.
And what is X star?
X star is just the set
of all maximizers X.
It could be unique.
There could be many.
But each one of them,
if there are many,
has to have the
property that evaluating
the function f at that
maximizer x gives you V back.
And again, everything
is indexed by t.
Now for the big E. If you took
the derivative of the value
function with respect to t,
even though t is a parameter,
it will be the derivative
of the underlying
function you're
trying to maximize
at the optimized solution.
That is for an x in the
set of maximizers at t.
So one thing to say this is
an example of that, right?
We wanted the profit
function, which
is parameterized
by not t, but p,
and we wanted to know how it
would behave at the optimum
if we were to slightly
change the parameter p.
And we just took the derivative
of the objective function
at the optimizing
solution, which
here is what this line is
at, the optimizing solution.
And the derivative was just z.
Well, at the risk of
confusing the issue,
there was this chat
going on about lambda
as the margin utility of income
in the consumers problem.
And, again, income was a
parameter of the problem.
And nevertheless, we wanted to
know how utility would change--
in this case, utility f--
how utility would change as we
change that parameter income i.
And the answer from the
envelope theorem is it
is the derivative of a
maximized objective function--
that is to say, of utility
substituting in the budget
constraint--
at parameter i.
So that's consistent
with this language
of the marginal
utility of income.
In the chat, there
is a great discussion
about that Lagrangian, which
is so powerful it's mysterious,
because the Lagrangian has
those Lagrange multipliers types
constraints, not just
the objective function.
So the chat was, it's not really
marginal utility because it's
a Lagrangian.
It didn't just write down
the utility term, et cetera,
et cetera.
But you can see how it--
hopefully get a little more
intuition about that problem
from the envelope theorem.
OK, so, as I said before, in
many applications that we're
clear about what's an
input and what's an output,
we could have, for
example, n possible inputs
and m possible
outputs, and then we'd
be writing these vectors
as negatives for the n
inputs and positive [INAUDIBLE]
m outputs [INAUDIBLE]
some degrees of freedom,
depending on the production
function.
The other things being 0.
There are things other firms
can do this firm cannot.
So we could maximize if--
even easier.
There's a single output and
capital N possible inputs.
We can talk about a
production function.
Rice is a function of labor,
holding capital and land fixed,
for example.
Or we could have
multiple vectors x--
land, labor, and capital.
And we write down this output
function, this production
function.
We will have prices of the
output p, say, taken as given.
We'll have the prices
of the N inputs, W1
through wn taken as given.
And we can write down
the profit maximization
problem, now with a bit
more intuitive signs.
It's revenue, price times
output, minus the cost
of the inputs that were used to
create that output at the price
is wn.
If f is differentiable, then
we can look for the first order
conditions.
That derivative's equal to 0.
Say, in particular with
respect to the nth input,
we'll get p times the derivative
of [? f of ?] xn over here,
and we'll get wn here.
That's just expression.
So the shorthand
way to say this is
the value of the marginal
product or the marginal revenue
product is equal to the price.
That's economist speak.
If you think about what
would happen when this is,
say, greater than the right-hand
side, that means one more
unit of input costs you wn.
But that input applied to
the production function
gives you a marginal output,
and that marginal output
evaluated at the price gives
you the marginal revenue.
So if the left-hand
side is greater
than the right-hand
side, you can't
be done because you get more
out of increasing your costs.
You more balance your costs
by increasing your revenue.
And likewise, when the
inequality goes the other way,
you've gone too far and used
up too much of the inputs.
So this is a very
intuitive expression.
So now let's talk about
cost minimization.
Instead of solving
the global problem
and finding the
maximizing profit,
maximizing inputs
and outputs, we're
going to break the
problem into pieces
and take the output
y as a given,
like something exogenous.
Got to do it.
Got to achieve it.
But let's achieve it in
the cost minimizing way.
So here's a statement
of the problem.
If this V of y is the input set
that delivers y as the output,
taking y as given, we can
choose any input vector, as long
as it gives us the output of y.
So let's minimize the
cost, the dot product w
times x, which is the cost
for achieving that output y.
And let's call that
the cost function.
It's the cost of producing y
in the least possible cost way,
given input, price, vector w.
The price of output
doesn't matter here
because that's a given anyway.
That is to say, price
is not only given.
Output is given.
So revenue is not
in question here.
It's just the cost of financing
it through the inputs.
So we'll call the solution
conditional factor demands.
And in principle,
they're a function
of these parameters W and y.
So let me draw you a picture.
In this case, there's going
to be an output level.
That's to think of
it as a single good.
q is the level.
And we're going to plot--
and there's two
inputs, x1 and x2.
And we're going to plot here the
set of all inputs that give you
the same output.
That's that curve.
Since the quantity is
the same, namely q,
we've got a name for this guy.
It's isoquant, which is
the final instance of iso
this and that.
So isoquant for same quantity
as we move along this isoquant.
And what are these
straight lines?
Our expenditure curves--
they're down here.
w times w1 x1 plus
w2 x2 equals c,
where c is some level of cost.
The higher ones are
associated with higher costs.
To minimize [INAUDIBLE]
one, move towards 0.
So the solution is here.
It's the minimized
cost that allows
you to be on the isoquant.
In fact, the way it's drawn, and
the other point on the isoquant
would give strictly
higher costs.
You with me?
So you can also
characterize this tangency.
The slope of this cost
line is w1 over w2.
The slope of the isoquant
is like a marginal rate
of substitution, except we call
it the marginal rate of product
transformation.
It's the rate at which you
can give up the use of input 2
and use input 1 in such a way as
to maintain quantity constant.
So this is very similar
to the indifference curve
that we had in consumer theory.
And this characterization
of the tangency
is similar in terms of the
ratios of the two tangent lines
being the same.
AUDIENCE: So the thing that's
getting toggled in this case
is the budget line, right?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: The thing
that we're trying to minimize
is cost.
So this, instead of
being a budget line,
it's an isocost line.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, and
we're trying to move this way
to make it as low as possible.
Yeah, so that's
another difference.
When we did utility
max, we had a budget,
and we were trying to maximize.
Although, we did in
the duality lecture
talk about minimizing
the cost of achieving
a certain level of utility,
and this is very close to that.
So here, we're
minimizing the cost
of achieving this
level of output.
OK, let me just say in words,
this is a particular q.
I could have picked another
one, which would minimize
the cost of achieving that q.
And then we would
get cost curves,
which are going to
show up momentarily.
But that was too much clutter
to put on the diagram,
so we didn't do it.
Instead, we put
on this, the idea
of changing the ratio of costs.
So say Disney Company producing
movies uses humans, animators,
and computers.
[INAUDIBLE] the year,
computers got cheaper relative
to the wages of humans.
So in the early 1900s,
1990s, the slope of this line
would be the cost
of computers divided
by the cost of animators--
relatively flat.
By today's standards,
the line is steeper.
So the cost of
computers, well-- it's--
always have to remember,
it's like p1 over p2.
So the cost of animators
relative to the cost
of computers has
become a lot steeper.
And of course, you're seeing
different tangencies A and B.
Naturally, Walt
Disney Company would
switch in the direction
of using the cheaper
input, namely, computers at the
expense of using more humans.
So later, when we get
into international trade,
we're going to talk about--
we're going to talk about
changing factor prices
and wages and so on,
so this is motivation
for that when we get there.
Cost function is
homogeneous of degree 1.
If you double the inputs,
you double the cost.
Same argument as before.
We're not going to
change the optimum.
We're just changing the
prices of the inputs,
so the cost doubles.
The cost function is continuous,
and the cost function
is concave.
Just like we did that the
profit function was convex,
we're getting that this
cost function is concave.
And the argument
is very similar.
And instead of
chewing up time, I'm
actually going to break
precedent and leave
this for you to do,
but it's exactly
the same argument
that we went through
with the convexity of
the profit function,
except the signs are--
the inequalities
go the other way.
OK, and then we get
Shepard's lemma,
which is a version of
Hotelling's lemma focusing
on costs, and hence only
on the inputs prices.
If we differentiate
the minimized cost
of producing output level y with
respect to an input price w--
I pride myself on the ability
to go through these slides
and remove all the typos.
But here, I'm kind of
wishing that I had had
a wn on here because it's xn.
So if there's only
one input, it's fine.
If there's multiple inputs,
then there's a vector,
and we should be
differentiating with respect
to a particular item in the
vector, namely, the nth input.
So probably better to
have written this as wn
and have an xn over here.
Anyway, hopefully, we'll
take notes and correct that.
It's not wrong.
It could have been
written better.
But the real point is
you've seen this before.
This is a version of
Hotelling's lemma.
It's called Shepard's lemma.
But Shepard's only dealing
with cost function.
Hotelling was dealing with
the whole profit function.
So all that stuff about
the envelope theorem,
blah, blah, blah,
that all applies here.
Cost curves-- so we've got
the total cost of producing q
as the minimized
cost of producing q.
The marginal cost is
the derivative of that.
And the average cost is total
cost divided by the quantity q.
That's the cost on average
of the various units of q.
Of course, profits would be
just the revenue minus the cost.
This is the minimized
cost function
suppressing the reference
to w as if it were fixed.
And take the derivative of this,
of course with respect to q,
we're getting a price
on the left-hand side
and the marginal
cost on the right.
So again, this
has an intuitive--
you've probably seen this in
your principles of economics
course, that when the
firm is optimizing,
it should pick a
quantity q, where price
is equal to marginal cost.
And the reason is, of
course, if price were greater
than marginal cost,
you get more in revenue
for one more unit than you
sacrifice in terms of costs
and vice versa when
it goes the other way.
In particular-- we're going to
get a strong property here--
when we have constant
returns to scale,
this production function you've
seen before, production set.
And the cost is
going to be linear.
It just scales up and
down as you vary q.
And in other words,
the marginal cost
is equal to the
average cost, and we
want to find the point when
you're optimizing the price
p is equal to the marginal
cost, which is also
equal to the average cost.
So any price less
than that, you're
like, no, I'm not doing it.
And any price greater, they
would go to infinity and make
an infinite amount of money.
And at this critical
price p, which is exactly
equal to the constant
marginal cost,
because the slope is the
same on this line everywhere,
they jump from 0 to any
old q that you want.
Let me show you the intuition
of what's going on here.
Again, keep track of
what's in the numerator
and what's in the denominator.
This is supposed
to be p1 over p2.
The slope of this isoprofit
line is p1 over p2.
If p2 is going up, this
isoprofit line slope
will be going down.
So let's compare the
three diagrams here.
So here, given a slope
associated with p1 over p2,
profits just get
higher and higher
as you move further and
further along the boundaries.
So 2 is the output.
So as p2 goes up, p1
over p2 is going down.
So we get this
isoprofit line, which
is actually coincident with the
boundary of the production set.
And finally, for--
so the mistake
here is this should
say going down.
I'm constantly catching
myself that it wasn't working
that the slope is moving in
the direction of the opposite
of what I'm saying.
What we want here is a price
where they go-- or infinity
over here.
They're indifferent at
this price of output.
And at a lower price
of output, they,
don't want to do anything.
So [INAUDIBLE] nothing
[? pro ?] profit.
And that's where these lines are
steeper, where these isoprofit
lines are steeper.
And they're steeper because
it has a slope of p1 or p2.
And the price of
output p2 has gotten
so low that these lines are
getting so steep that the best
position is zero profit, so I
finally set it right that time.
And I did not catch
this typo before.
We'll fix that.
The point of the diagram is
constant returns to scale
has some very
special properties.
Prices have to be just right.
If price ratio is just right,
then any production is fine,
and they're making zero profits.
So they don't care.
They will do something if
demand makes them do it.
But on these two extremes,
this isn't feasible
because it's infinite profit.
And here, they
would make losses,
so they minimize their
losses and go to 0.
So you get these very
extreme solutions.
If you have an equilibrium
with positive profits
from a production set which
displays constant returns
to scale, you know
that the price ratio
has to be coincident with
the slope of the boundary
of the production function.
When we get to equilibrium,
we can determine prices
from the production side,
at least on the premise
that something's being produced.
That's what I said.
This is a property of
constant returns to scale.
Namely, we might just as well
solve the cost minimization
problem for an output
of 1 and get the ratio
of the inputs that way.
And then, if you want
to scale production
up or down, y being greater than
or less than 1, that's fine.
You'll change the
level of the inputs.
They're going to scale up and
down as well by the same scalar
you're using to scale y, but
the ratio isn't going to move.
But that's a property of
constant returns to scale.
Now, again, I had
decided this in advance
and, indeed, have my
eyes on the clock here.
There is a proof here.
So if you like, take some
time and try to write out
a proof by contradiction.
I think you'll find that
to be a useful exercise.
In other words,
prove something like
suppose you changed y and the
input ratio were to change,
then that would lead to a
contradiction, something
inconsistent with
constant returns to scale.
All right, here's
Robinson Crusoe.
It's like a one-island,
one-man economy.
If you don't the story,
this means nothing to you.
I think he actually had
a helper called Friday.
But anyway, just think
of Robinson Crusoe being
a one-man economy, and we plot
the production possibility set
with Robinson's input, getting
food as output, picking fruit
off the trees, whatever.
And what's the maximal
solution for Robinson?
It's to find the
utility function which
has the highest tangency.
So these lines are the curves
of indifference curves,
and the maximal utility
level is [INAUDIBLE]..
So this is kind of a big
moment in the course,
even though the
concepts probably
look pretty transparent.
We just combined utility
maximization with production.
And I'm telling you, the optimum
point for the whole economy
is this tangency level.
And, actually, if
we drew a line that
were tangent to
both the production
boundary and the
indifference curve,
that could represent
both a profit line
for Robinson Crusoe, the
producer, and a budget line
for Robinson Crusoe
as a consumer.
So for the first
time, we're actually
looking at a
competitive equilibrium
for the whole economy.
It's kind of stupid, though,
because Robinson's all alone.
There's no one to trade with.
But suppose he could.
So suppose Robinson
Crusoe could produce
two goods, some
agricultural output,
but also some tools or
some manufactured good
on the x-axis.
So the set of
production possibilities
is this quarter circle
area with its boundary.
And if Robinson Crusoe would
be still intent on maximizing
utility, we'd find where the
slope of the-- where the--
we'd find the highest
level of the indifference
curve and the tangency.
There's stuff going on
in the background here
I'm not showing you
to make it simpler.
I'm not talking about his input.
[INAUDIBLE] whether I'm going
to work in agriculture or work
in manufacturing, and I'm not
showing you that work level.
But it is producing this set
of production possibilities
of the two goods,
and this would be
the utility maximizing point A.
Now, suppose all of a sudden,
he has the opportunity
to trade with another island.
And suppose we represent
the isoprofit line in red.
So we want to be as far to
the northeast as possible,
maximizing profits, but staying
on the production possibility
set.
So that maximized
level of production
is here, B, and
consumption is here, C.
Now, this is a much
more interesting economy
because there's some
external agent here.
[INAUDIBLE] Robinson
Crusoe and the rest
of the world, that other island.
And they're now trading
with each other.
And Robinson Crusoe has
decided to specialize more,
though not completely,
in manufacturing goods
and to give them up in
trade to the other island
in order to acquire more
agricultural output.
So we're seeing exports and
imports as we move from B to C.
And, obviously, Robinson Crusoe
is doing better utility wise
from trade than that autarky.
A might stand for autarky.
So this is our first glimpse
at the gains from trade.
With the one-man
economy, at least,
Robinson Crusoe can be
made better off by trading
with another island.
This is a related picture.
Suppose we have two countries,
the UK and the United States,
and their production
possibility set
look different from each other.
We're plotting wheat and
cloth in both countries,
and we might have an autarky
that the UK's maximal utility
position is here at DUK, and
that the US's no-trade position
would be at DUS.
Now, you do see that
this is deliberately
chosen so the slopes of
these lines are different,
and that suggests there
are gains to trade.
In fact, what's depicted
here is almost common
price ratio, where you could
think of it as the prices
in the rest of the world.
But this may be a
bilateral country example,
but somehow the prices
are fixed for each country
by competitive forces.
So the slope of the dashed line
is the same for both countries.
And what happens?
Well, the UK decides to
export wheat and import cloth.
I thought it was going to
go the other way, actually.
And the United
States chooses to--
did I just say that wrong--
chooses to-- oh, yeah,
I did say it wrong.
The US chooses to produce
more wheat and export
part of that increased
production back to the UK.
The UK was here in
autarky, when it
faced with the
possibility of trade,
it produces much
more cloth, and then
it exports that cloth to the US.
Cloth and the UK
kind go hand-in-hand
because people think of
the Industrial Revolution
and manufacturing
of textiles, which
was kind over big deal in
Britain, and the US and Kansas
and so on having lots of wheat.
So it's meant to be a
somewhat realistic example.
Anyway, this is the
climax of the slides today
because you're seeing an
application of production
theory, in particular, a
profit maximizing theory,
but now integrating with
utility maximization theory
and looking at an equilibrium
of an entire economy, at least
consisting of two countries.
When we talk about tariffs
and taxes and so on,
these dashed lines will
not be of identical slope.
They're going to have different
slopes in different countries,
depending on which good
is subject to a tariff.
Imports from China
coming into the US,
for example, are
subject to a tariff.
And we'll get there, but
we're getting very close now.
So there is more to this part
of the lecture on production,
but I preplanned to stop here to
say, next time, when we start,
we'll finish up this production
lecture on Leontief and Google,
Facebook page rank, I mean, and
the great Japanese earthquake,
and then we'll--
which are fun applications
for production.
And then we're going to
go to lecture 5 and talk
about the consumer
theory and then
combine them all over
again with some techniques
on linear programming.
OK, see you soon.